de sa ligne avec un défenseur maintenant
que le ballon c'était pas une place
c'est pas un match où on peut juger je
libère on va être attendu il va être
attendu sur la gestion et là il a fait
pas grand chose à gérer il avait rien à
gérer j'allais bien on va l'attendre sur
l'Italie on va l'attendre en quart de
finale c'est là où il va devoir faire
plus que ces petits coups de pied par
dessus
et aller nous soulager aller un petit
peu franchement savoir alterner ce que
fait très bien de tabac quoi vous étiez
bien placé Vincent roserand dans le
stade Vélodrome c'est où la tribune de
presse
alors la tribune de presse est très
haute mais par contre on voit pas très
bien le bas du terrain on va dire on
peut pas voir un côté du terrain si on
se lève pas en fait donc c'était pas non
plus extrêmement bien donc il faut se
lever assez souvent mais en tout cas
bien sûr on voit bien on voit bien ce
qui se passe moi je vais très un petit
bémol de toujours très compliqué dans un
dans un match comme ça ou tout se
déroule quand même très bien mais movaca
qui a fait une excellente d'excellents
premier match là
sans sur la défense mais sur les touches
par exemple il a eu du mal au début à se
régler et aussi des des un en avant sur
sur une action où il aurait pu y aller
on l'a senti moins en dedans que sur les
précédents matchs
bon avoir Alexandre Bertolini tiens je
suis obligé de vous interroger il est
23h14 l'équipe de France c'est largement
imposé contre la Namibie elle a fait le
travail et même mieux que ça on espérait
pas tant leur de nos pronostics avant la
rencontre mais le fait du mal c'est
évidemment la blessure d'Antoine Dupont
vous votre mon avis est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet je suis très très inquiet c'est
pas bon signe qu'on n'est pas de
nouvelles et le grand problème c'est que
finalement ce qu'on va retenir de ce
match si Antoine Dupont est blessé on
oubliera tous les beaux essais on
oubliera même le record parce que
blessure Antoine Dupont c'est quand même
le fait majeur si il est blessé et s'il
est touché pommette ou blanchir orbital
on reverra plus la Coupe du monde donc
ça pourrait être très grave mais on sait
pas encore on va espérer que ça soit pas
aussi grave mais ça serait un coup
vraiment terrible pour le coup pour les
Bleus c'est ce qui vous a plu dans ce
dans ce match je vais reprendre les
mêmes questions que à nos amis qu'est-ce
que vous retenez sur quoi faut-il
s'appuyer
le problème c'est que l'adversaire a été
quand même extrêmement faible donc c'est
compliqué de dire qu'on peut justement
très peu de de fautes de main on a quand
même très bien joué avec le ballon après
même si du coup la défense très peu on
en a vu une peut-être bien Loiret
justement sur une base de Queneau une de
d'anti en fin de rencontre aussi mais
dans l'ensemble
voilà donc parce que les plaquages sont
moins virés
absent de se concentration de cette
équipe alors que là ils étaient ils
étaient dans le même si on voulait se
précipiter alors exactement oui c'est
vrai à jouer tous les ballons Presque
Oui à prendre des risques inconsidérés
alors qu'il faisait d'être patient on se
débarrasser du ballon alors que là les
types étaient placés il y avait des
courses à côté du porteur il avait le
choix donc les ballons arrivent bien et
c'est les gens sont concentrés et qui
vous a déçus
côté français j'ai pas de déception
après côté namibien on peut quand même
se demander ce qu'il faisait ah oui
alors tiens ça qu'est-ce qu'ils font en
Coupe du Monde la nuit
50 questions je politique c'est presque
une question géopolitique qu'est-ce
qu'ils font là les amis bien après c'est
vrai que c'est une nation historique du
rugby qui est comme un grand passif ça
fait quasiment un siècle qui est du
rugby en Namibie mais après c'est vrai
que bah il y a des équipes comme la
Roumanie le Chili mais est-ce que c'est
vraiment faire un cadeau assez nations
de venir prendre 86
et que c'est à la Coupe du Monde qui
peuvent affronter les grandes équipes
parce qu'après sinon ils font très peu
de matchs j'entends mais moi je suis une
nation qui veut me développer en rugby
je vois ça je me dis ouais je vais
peut-être mettre sur autre chose vous
voyez ce que je veux dire l'argent mais
après le bah là pour le problème de la
Libye pour la Roumanie c'est quand même
un sport historique donc il y a que
cette compétition là pour jouer contre
les grosses nations et que il y a très
peu de matchs après comparé aux grandes
nations je crois que le Namibie avant de
avant avant la Coupe du monde ils
avaient fait ouais en 4 ans ils avaient
fait 8 10 matchs donc ça fait ça fait
peu en tout cas pour former des
automatismes le Japon prenait des
fessées absolument démente et puis quand
ils ont décidé d'organiser la Coupe du
monde ils sont équipés la Coupe du monde
dans un pays comme ça pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs mais je pense qu'ils auraient
du mal mais
enfin le Japon a prouvé que en se
strurant on peut à l'arriver à avoir une
équipe nationale qui ressemble à quelque
chose autour de vous avec les
journalistes ce qu'on se demande ce que
fait l'anamibie est-ce qu'on était
moqueur en tribune
oui on a été moqueur surtout à la
mi-temps c'est quand même dit que
c'était pas une super pub pour du rugby
quand même effectivement de voir ce
qu'on a vu aujourd'hui parce que on voit
que c'est quand même un match
extrêmement déséquilibré que c'est voilà
on le disait aussi la dernière fois
c'est que on est on a une nation qui est
pas si loin que ça au classement c'est
en foot on imagine j'aimerais le premier
contre le 22e ce serait pas ce serait
pas complètement fou là effectivement
sur un match comme ça les amis bien ils
ont pas existé du match ils ont ils ont
rien réussi à faire et on se demande
effectivement qu'est-ce qu'ils font là
mais qu'est-ce qu'ils font là bah il
faut deux équipes africaines à la Coupe
du monde et ils se sont qualifiés quand
même et si c'est pas eux c'est une autre
équipe africaine et je vous rappelle que
eux ils se sont qualifiés en mettant en
collant à 38 0 face au Kenya il me
semble et c'est ça qui nous disait avant
match que contre la Côte d'Ivoire là
aussi ça avait été une large victoire
sur la scène africaine il débattent à
pas de couture les autres nations donc
ce serait pire du coup notre équipe bon
cette équipe alors on pas de nouvelles
d'Antoine Dupont on va essayer d'en
prendre est-ce que cette équipe là ce 15
là peut aller au bout après ce que vous
avez vu et imaginons ce 15 là sans
Antoine Dupont parce que là visiblement
les nouvelles sont mauvaises est-ce que
cette équipe peut être championne du
monde et ce qu'il peut y avoir du
changement ou non il y aurait des
ajustements de Galtier Alexandre j'ai
envie de dire que sans Dupont on est
plus du tout favori ouais après on a on
a il y a longtemps on avait fait une
tournée en Australie où c'était l'équipe
C et qu'on avait quand même réussi à
gagner un match en Australie il fait
gagner la tournée donc on sait qu'aussi
parfois les joueurs qu'on n'attend pas
savent se transcender couillou fait
quand même un très bon match après les
matchs de phase finale la pression va
être énorme donc il serait capable de
les de les louper de de perdre son
niveau voilà
une habitude des matchs en jeu que que
n'a pas forcément
après au niveau des ajustements là on
est quand même pas loin de la top
équipes il manquait juste alright
et marchand et marche effectivement qui
va revenir en plus donc en fait c'est
toujours très solide c'est juste qu'on
est mal habitué ces derniers temps on a
une équipe de rêve mais même sans Dupont
on a toujours nos chances même si
évidemment on le précise pour l'instant
Antoine Dupont on n'est pas forcément on
attend les nouvelles Jean-Marc votre
avis sur cette équipe je pense qu'on a
une très belle équipe alors
effectivement du pont c'est Monsieur
plus voilà c'est bon c'est un facteur
qui enfin le voit quand il est beaucoup
plus surveillé aujourd'hui qu'autrefois
dès qu'il prend peu d'espace bon même
quand il y a pas d'espace il s'est
orienté le jeu mais en plus quand on lui
il en trouve un peu voilà c'est l'arme
fatale donc évidemment que c'est un
atout majeur pour être en plus en France
et puis je me répète mais il a de
l'expérience par rapport bon le cul en a
mais enfin
en cuir rugby plus expérience
internationale il est inégalé et c'est
le meilleur du monde de très loin
François c'était cette équipe est-ce
qu'elle vous a convaincu vous étiez avec
David rayra et Arnaud Coudry les
spécialistes rugby à côté de vous quand
il dit de ce 15 là aligné par Galtier
je vais être complètement honnête avec
vous je n'ai pas regardé le match à côté
d'eux donc je n'ai pas eu ce qu'ils
m'ont dit mais par contre à la mi-temps
j'ai pu discuter avec un autre coup de
riz qui m'a dit que lui il avait vu une
équipe de France qui s'était remis à
l'endroit et qui et qui ici elle était
dans cette configuration avant la
blessure de Dupont on était une équipe
jean-margonale disait l'an dernier la
semaine dernière face à l'Uruguay on
avait peut-être perdu notre statue de
numéro 1 alors certes c'est la namibus
et que la permittent mais je pense qu'à
la mi-temps on peut se dire que là on
avait repris ce statut numéro 1 parce
que tout marché extrêmement bien et la
question c'est est-ce que c'est la même
chose sans Antoine Dupont mais une fois
de plus moi je ne le pense pas forcément
Vincent maillet qui lui dit dans le dans
le chat à utiliser un gros mot mégaltier
un mec comme Dupont tu le préserves à
fond ça fait 11 mois qu'il est en CAN
qu'est-ce qu'il a approuvé
il a approuvé qu'il peut jouer à côté
d'un lit d'ouverture avec lequel il a
pas l'habitude de jouer rien que ça
c'est énorme et c'est un Tama qui joue
en club avec lui je les yeux fermés avec
avec Jalibert c'est plus compliqué si
vous ne rejoignez c'est
du football c'est une comparaison
totalement adulte déjà en football on
parle de cohésion mais on peut
additionner le talent plus facilement en
football en rugby il faut des automatis
c'est des gens qui jouent à côté les uns
des autres c'est un mécanisme
d'horlogerie c'est très complexe il y a
un débat en plateau pour savoir si
Fabien Galtier a fait une erreur
Jean-Marc Gonin et Jean en plateau
disent qu'il fallait le faire jouer
et moi je défends ce que je lis sur Le
Figaro.fr les gens sont des soutiens
Alexandre vous n'avez pas répondu est-ce
que du coup on devait jouer déjà et ce
qu'il devait sortir plutôt bien sûr
qu'il devait jouer d'autant que
Jean-Marc parler d'automatisme et c'est
encore plus vrai à la charnière parce
que c'est vraiment vous me faites
doucement rigoler pardon je vous le
redis vous êtes les experts non mais il
y a une semaine avant match on me disait
non non les tauliers et Antoine Dupont
on le revoit pas avant l'Italie alors
vous étiez pas là mais les gens sur ce
plateau ils disaient ça
là aujourd'hui vous me dites si si
fallait tout prix le faire jouer contre
la tamibie je suis désolé le son
d'Uruguay c'était que on avait pas
d'équipe B réellement qu'il fallait
remettre les tauliers et en plus il y
avait la deuxième chose
le match du pack contre l'Uruguay qui
n'était pas des terreur soyons sérieux
il était désastreux on avait besoin de
mettre des tôliers je vous donne la
parole de quel côté vous rangez-vous
Fabien Galtier a-t-il fait une erreur
oui ou non
je pense que non Fabien gatine n'a pas
fait une erreur on lui en aurait
reproché on va pas mettre Antoine Dupont
au frigo aussi longtemps on parlait
effectivement les automatismes au rugby
c'est important c'est important de
d'avoir une bonne charnière on a pu
romain une thamac alors que Romain Tama
qui joue en club avec avec Antoine
Dupont du coup il faut les faire jouer
ensemble et il fallait les faire jouer
aujourd'hui je pense ensemble après oui
le rugby comme chez jean-margonien aussi
au début cette émission le rugby est un
sport de contact le rugby est un sport
on se blesse assez souvent quand même et
on peut perdre un joueur aussi important
que ça je vous rappelle quoi toujours
pas perdu tout de même mais on peut
perdre
un joueur comme ça
on peut se fracturer la pommette à
l'entraînement oui parce que comme ça
il y a des entraînements avec contact et
sans contact les entraînements avec
contact ils sont rude et
vous voyez dans toutes les équipes de
coupe du monde il y a des vraies graves
à l'entraînement donc c'est un sport de
contact comme tous voilà on voulait la
réaction de jellonge alors il parle pas
de d'Antoine Dupont
qu'est-ce qu'il dit on a mis les on a
mis les bons ingrédients voilà ce qu'il
dit je longe on s'est dit qu'on allait
jouer ce soir comme si on jouait un
match de phase finale et je crois qu'on
a mis les bons ingrédients on a mis du
combat et quand on joue à ce niveau
c'est normal qu'on gagne voilà la
réaction Antony jonche on attend les
premières
sorties des joueurs du XV de France sur
la blessure d'Antoine Dupont et son
départ pour l'hôpital on rappelle qu'il
y a une suspicion de fractures de la
pommette ou du planche orbitale et puis
d'une commotion cérébrale un mot quand
même une bonne nouvelle dans la soirée
penaud triplé et il se rapproche du
record Kevin oui c'est ça donc on espère
qu'il va en tout cas en équipe de France
il va également le record de Vincent
Clerc contre l'Italie et puis après pour
cet argent peut-être Mathieu de BLANCO
donc oui une des satisfactions en tout
cas et c'est vrai qu'en tout cas ça
faisait plaisir de le voir jouer à un
tel niveau est-ce que c'est lui le
monsieur qui est derrière moi est-ce que
c'est lui qui en cas d'absence d'Antoine
Dupont devient la star des Bleus
c'est compliqué il y a aussi quand même
Grégory aldritz particulièrement
monstrueux
exactement pour le grand public une
coupe du monde il n'y a pas que des
spécialistes qui regardent alors on
regarde les joueurs flamboyants est-ce
que c'est lui qui peut amener
l'étincelle alors mais l'étincelle c'est
sûr effectivement c'est les gens vont
retenir pono parce qu'ils souvent il est
à la conclusion des essais et puis il
fait quand même des actions assez
incroyables c'est quand même le seul
joueur qui quand il fait des travers on
s'inquiète pas alors que normalement
c'est un truc en école de rugby on nous
apprend de surtout pas faire ça c'est
quand même étrange qu'il fasse autant ça
mais lui ça marche
Travis sur Damien openo
mentalité d'une star il est assez star
lui-même
là-dessus
Vivaro en équipe de France on les réduit
un peu la tête ces dernières années
parce qu'il était un peu hablar à une
époque mais voilà costa il a c'est une
star discutablement parce qu'il y a un
style de jeu
s'emploi pas trop en défense parfois
mais dès qu'il faut marquer des essais
il est remarquable il y a rien à dire
Vincent roseron sur place est-ce que
Damian penaud est une start tiens qui
est le joueur qui suscite le plus
d'enthousiasme des qui touche le ballon
ça on arrive à le sentir quand on est
dans le stade
oui Antoine Dupont 100% Antoine Dupont à
l'annonce de son nom on entend toujours
beaucoup beaucoup crier on a vu aussi
oui alors vous voulez savoir qui d'autre
a été extrêmement applaudit vous voulez
savoir qui d'autre aussi est extrêmement
applaudit et ben romain quand la caméra
est passée sur lui figurez-vous très
très applaudi donc ça va pas forcément
être ça pas forcément être mieux mais
non je longe je longe est très apprécié
aussi sûrement avec son avec son retour
de blessure d'anti aussi a été a été
célébré forcément au moment de ces de
ses essais on l'a senti et voilà et puis
penaud oui forcément sur sur CDC il est
voilà il provoque toujours quelque chose
et il est très je sais pas comment vous
dire mais il est très très efficace
forcément merci
une star qui est en train d'arriver
c'est bien le biais je me répète avec sa
gueule d'ange c'est 20 ans son casque
rouge je pense que on va beaucoup le
voir
parce qu'il y a des joueurs voyage il y
a un joueur que tous les deux en
regardant on s'est dit Thibault flamand
il excellent on en a pas dit un mot
c'est un sport ingraal rugby parfois
des réseaux sociaux qui est avec nous
alors vous avez suivi le match avec nous
et puis vous l'avez suivi aussi sur sur
Internet qu'est-ce qu'il ressort
j'imagine qu'on doit beaucoup parler
d'Antoine Dupont mais allez-y peut-être
que ce coup dur les couteaux sont le
cœur lourd l'euphorie est bien bien
retombé mais grâce à vibrer notre outil
de veille des réseaux sociaux je peux
vous donner le nombre de tweets oui
généré par cette rencontre 90000 alors
ça on le verra tout de suite après c'est
le les joueurs les plus cités mais donc
90000 tweets c'est 1,8 fois de moins par
rapport à France Uruguay donc les gens
ont un peu moins réagi mais là j'imagine
que après le match il s'inquiète tous de
l'état de santé d'Anthon
duboiseurs quand même dans ce match le
score qui est quasiment jamais vu et
puis presque surtout cette blessure
d'Antoine Dupont on va montrer ce
graphique il est très intéressant et je
vous laisse le commenter donc si tu es
près de 3000 fois évidemment Antoine
Dupont arrive en numéro 1 suiv Damian
penaud évidemment qui est Alexandre l'a
dit qui est flamboyant fulgurant et qui
devient très très populaire auprès des
supporters des Bleus la petite pépite
jeune Louis bielle biarrhée arrive en 3e
position avec près de 530 interactions
et puis Matthieu Jalibert et Charles
Olivon et Olivon qui a mis un
triplés
pour pour lui oui on voit Antoine Dupont
qui a suscité beaucoup de réactions sur
les réseaux sociaux et puis ensuite le
prochain tweet une phrase terrible mais
qui résume peut-être la soirée je sais
pas si on peut le voir voilà la France
vient de gagner 96 à zéro et de perdre
la Coupe du monde alors c'est peut-être
un tweet un peu péremptoire mais
oui c'est tout ce qui est la question
qu'on se pose tous après il faut savoir
qu'en sport parfois les équipes quand
elles perdent leurs joueurs star elles
se soude encore plus et se sentent les
tripes encore plus donc ça peut aussi
c'est ce qu'on appelle senti après la
blessure de Romain TAMAK mais là il va
falloir trouver des exemples parce que
moi je vois plus d'équipes qui gagnent
avec leur star avec le New Wilkinson
avec Bryan Habana avec donaldo
Antoine Dupont bon sur une autre plus
positive je vous ai mis ce petit tweet
un peu marrant du community manager de
l'équipe de France de rugby officiel qui
dit ça va trop vite il avait même pas le
temps de oui parce que comment tu es il
met des tweets à chaque fois qu'il y a
un essai il y avait tellement d'essai
une ribambelle DC au fil de la rencontre
qu'il avait même pas le temps
d'actualiser sur le propre compte
Twitter du du de France donc c'est c'est
marrant et puis dernier tweet un clin
d'oeil vous l'avez dit il est très
populaire aussi à Romain TAMAK qui était
présent sur place à Marseille aux côtés
de son coéquipier en club Julien
marchand voilà venu soutenir l'équipe de
France mais on espère que Antoine Dupont
ne sera pas dans le même état
les nouvelles sont sont pas hyper
rassurantes pour l'instant allez on se
projette sur sur la suite il est 23h31
l'équipe de France vient de remporter
largement son troisième match de la
Coupe du monde face à la Namibie 96 0
c'est un record
elle est en tête de son groupe et
maintenant France-Italie alors
France-Italie il va être intéressant
puisque potentiellement les Italiens
peuvent encore nous éliminer c'est
possible c'est possible alors déjà il
faudrait qu'il prenne le bonus face au
black c'est possible un bonus défensif
on y croit moyen
ça sera compliqué quand même faut pas
les enterrer trop vite quand même
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont ils sont ils ont
une satur assez solide vous avez vu
jouer d'ailleurs contre cette équipe de
la Namibie contre la Namibie à
Saint-Étienne
ils ont un jeune pack une bonne
troisième ligne c'est vraiment solide
leur premier leur première ligne tient
le choc
ils ont un très bon buteur il y aura
très peu de points donc on sait jamais
il tomberait sur une Nouvelle-Zélande
dans un jour sans il pourrait sortir
avec un avec un bonus c'est possible ça
y croyez l'Italie qui ferait une partie
du travail face à la Nouvelle-Zélande et
qui offrirait un match vraiment décisif
face à ça qu'on a vu une équipe de vol
Zélande qui était pas la meilleure
possible après ils sont un peu rassurés
aussi contre la Namibie mais c'est vrai
que ça reste à jouer qu'on a ce sera le
premier véritable test aussi pour
l'Italie qui a pour l'instant n'a pas
joué contre des grosses nations
en tout cas ils ont une équipe
intéressante après je les vois mal
battre la Nouvelle-Zélande en tout cas
ils peuvent là
résistance
ou non il faut pas exagérer un scénario
catastrophe c'est possible ça l'Italie
le point du bonus et puis derrière un
match compliqué tendu contre nous déjà
on va pas le souhaiter mais surtout
extrêmement improbable oui parce que 91%
de victoire face à l'Italie dans
l'histoire des confrontations l'équipe
de France quand on a perdu contre
l'Italie on était quand même très
mauvais aussi oui donc là aujourd'hui le
différentiel de niveau est quand même
assez énorme
et puis il prendront pas non plus
certainement le bonus défensif contre le
mauvaise langue parce que match contre
les petites équipes contrairement à
l'équipe de France qui parfois a
tendance à mal jouer comme quand Uruguay
la Nouvelle-Zélande culturellement
écrase les petites équipes et l'Italie
fait plutôt partie quand même des
petites équipes sélectionnant le black
deux semaines de deux semaines de pause
comment on gère et quelle équipe on
aligne face à l'Italie Antoine Dupont on
peut le dire il ne sera peut-être pas
forfait pour la suite de la Coupe du
monde mais contre l'Italie peu de chance
de le voir quoi qu'il arrive commotion
cérébrale avec une suspicion fracture
peut-être qu'on grandes chances qu'on le
préserve qu'est-ce l'équipe on met face
à l'Italie on remet les mêmes ou presque
Kevin oui je pense qu'on remet les mêmes
presque parce qu'après le garde finale
c'est l'Afrique du Sud ou Irlande donc
faudra faudra pas se cacher donc non
faut reprendre les mêmes et puis essayer
de construire ces automatismes avec bah
je pense ouais une charnière peut
sûrement on verra après par la suite
mais Antoine Dupont même s'il a une
commotion il fera pas l'Italie je pense
et vous faites quoi Alexandre vous
remettez la même équipe face à l'Italie
l'équipe avec si possible du coup
aldritement et la grande question c'est
vous sortez
effectivement c'est compliqué mais c'est
compliqué parce que là
c'est compliqué
et ensuite est-ce qu'on donne une
dernière chance à mainvillière
très très bon match à une époque en
équipe de France est-ce que l'Italie
normalement ça doit passer donc est-ce
qu'on peut le lui donner une dernière
chance
de reprendre sa place même si c'est
improbable voilà c'est sa tête game of
c'est pour ça que vous comprend pas vous
me dites l'Italie ça doit passer en
quelques remplaçants et vous me dites
qu'il fallait aligner la l'Armada contre
la Namibie enfin margonnin vous faites
quoi contre l'Italie la même équipe avec
on souhaite donc marchand reprenne la
place de talonneur parce que marchand
bovaca c'est quand même là aussi c'est
une double arme fatale c'est à dire que
quand on a pris pendant une mi-temps
comme talonneur marchand et qu'on prend
deuxième mi-temps novakage j'aimerais
pas être la première ligne d'en face
c'est très sincèrement donc ça c'est
quand même l'équipe de France de ce
point de vue là des ressources
profonde et puis moi je pense pas du
tout que je pense que Gabin Velia a
disparu de la circulation vous l'auriez
de la carte vous Vincent roseron
qu'est-ce que vous feriez si vous êtes
ces sélectionné et ensuite deuxième
question est-ce que vous avez des
nouvelles d'Antoine Dupont vous qui êtes
sur place alors je sais que vous êtes en
dehors du stade mais vous êtes en
contact étroit avec nos envoyés spéciaux
qui sont au plus proche du 15 de France
quel choix va faire Galtier les notes du
Figaro sont tombées avec donc Arnaud
Coudray davidreira en attendant les
informations pour Antoine Dupont qui
donne des nathal et essayer de deviner
qu'ils ont donné le la meilleure note et
de lyrics
peut-être bien le barré c'est non il a 8
un joueur à une neuf qui non
qui a une oeuf qui a eu la moins bonne
note
kevince avec les entrants aussi non non
je parle des titulaires
c'est compliqué
peut-être j'alibère mais ils sont deux
bail et woki
je vous donne une petite revue quand
même Ramos à 8 filles ou 7 d'anti 7,5 et
le bar et 8 je la libère non il le note
plutôt bien à 8 du pont à 8 je lance
on se peut demander qui qui remplacerait
dans ces parmi les trois cross à U7
Olivon et 8 et je longe a eu 6 et demi
voilà selon évidemment nos envies
spéciaux nos spécialistes rugby depuis
le stade vélodrome
de finisseur idéal dans le dans ce qui
peut je longe à l'avantage de pouvoir
entrer en 8 ou en flanquer oui donc il a
une grande polyvalence donc vous le
mettez sur le banc sauf qu'il rentre à
tous les coups il rentre assez tôt là où
il faut en forme vous pouvez le faire
finir un match il a il a de la force il
a du dynamisme et il a
vous en faites pas un vrai remplaçant
finalement vous faites le premier des
remplaçants
dans la caisse à outils c'est la clé qui
ouvre toutes les portes allez on se
penche sur un match qui est peut-être le
plus important de la semaine pour
l'équipe de France finalement c'est
celui de samedi soir Afrique du Sud
Irlande il détermine la suite de notre
compétition
Kevin alors on peut le dire simple le
perdant je vous raconte la France à
l'heure où on se parle c'est comme ça
que ça se passe qui va gagner ce match
et qui vous espérez voir gagner ce match
moi je préfère la jouer l'Irlande en
quart de finale mais d'accord et après
je pense que je vois plus l'Afrique du
Sud quand même d'un coup gagner quand
même ce match et après l'Irlande on
prend derrière enfin j'ai l'impression
que l'Irlande a quand même une très
bonne équipe c'est la première mondiale
mais ça tourne plus autour de Sexton
alors que finalement l'équipe d'Afrique
du Sud ils ont une force collective qui
est plus impressionnante vous faites
vous préférez quoi Alexandre vous
préférez jouer contre l'Irlande ou
contre l'Afrique du Sud en quart de
finale alors quoi qu'il arrive c'est un
très mauvais
je préférais l'Irlande parce que malgré
tout l'Afrique du Sud c'est encore plus
encore plus physique que l'Irlande et
puis c'est une équipe qu'on connaît un
peu moins bien aussi que l'Irlande
l'Irlande on savait à peu près les
manœuvrés jusqu'à cette année ou c'est
incliné chez eux ils ont fait un match
énorme donc plutôt l'Irlande parce que
l'Afrique du Sud c'est vraiment une
équipe redoutable je crois qu'ils ont
pris trois points en deux matchs ils ont
joué des cosses donc en défense et
monstrueux c'est extrêmement physique et
donc c'est aussi un match qui nous
fatiguerait énormément il pourrait y
avoir de la casse deux d'entre nous en
plateau préfère l'Irlande vous préférez
qui vous Jean-Marc le fruit du Sud et
oui non parce que je pense qu'on a on
est pratiquement la seule équipe au
monde avoir la densité physique qui
tient face au box premier point deuxième
point les box ils sont pas tout jeunes
troisième point que moi je trouve
toujours impressionnant quand je vois
l'Irlande certes on les connaît bien il
nous connaissent bien aussi c'est il
faut le savoir c'est qu'ils ont un
système de jeu absolument redoutable
c'est une machine infernale à affronter
comment ils attaquent ces espèces de
roulement permanent les redoublements de
passe c'est la seule équipe qui joue
avec un mécanisme aussi au point et
c'est des garçons qui jouent tous dans
le même club soleil deux exceptions près
et donc il se trouve les yeux fermés et
quand vous êtes en défense ces types là
vous arrive vague par vague dessus et
c'est une équipe très difficile à
maîtriser on a bien vu ce qu'on a donné
à Dublin cette année dans le tournoi
c'est très compliqué c'est très
compliqué
au stade Vélodrome est-ce qu'on a parlé
de cette rencontre en tribune est-ce que
c'était dans toutes les têtes est-ce que
au coup de sifflet final on s'est dit
allez maintenant il faut regarder ce qui
se passe samedi soir
je vous rappelle qu'on pense surtout à
ce qui se passe à l'hôpital du côté
d'Antoine Dupont oui alors
je n'en ai pas je n'en ai pas je vous
avais déjà j'aimerais beaucoup vous en
donner Thibault vous le savez mais je
n'en ai pas pour l'instant j'ai
j'attends d'en avoir moi aussi mais je
n'en ai pas et que ce soit sur la
question de effectivement qui affronter
entre l'Irlande et l'Afrique du Sud
c'est de très très grosses équipes
l'Irlande on peut se dire que vu qu'ils
nous ont battus dans Destination on va
vraiment avoir envie de se de se
racheter
je vois ce que vous voulez à quoi on
doit s'attendre samedi soir quel genre
de match très offensif match serré à
moins de 20 points chacun qu'est-ce
qu'on va voir Alexandre
parce que l'Irlande ça défend très bien
l'Afrique du Sud comme j'ai dit ils ont
pris trois points ça va être extrêmement
dense des je pense qu'on va avoir un
temps de jeu effectif énorme
et un match extrêmement physique assez
fermé au final sauf si une équipe se
détache mais pas trop vous êtes d'accord
avec ça oui match fermé match très
physique il y aura aussi de la casse
pour les deux équipes donc ce sera à
suivre et puis l'Afrique du Sud a déjà
joué l'Écosse alors qu'il Irlande devra
aussi se taper les gosses après donc ça
peut changer l'approche du mal que ça
pourra aussi favoriser mais bon après
comme vous le rappeliez l'Irlande c'est
quand même un système de jeu bien au
point et c'est vrai que ça fatigue des
défenses leur système de vagues quel
genre de match samedi soir je commence à
regarder dans le ciel
je pense
que ça va beaucoup jouer en l'air là
d'accord parce qu'il y a des gens qui
étaient très dangereux les défenses sont
fortes donc on va essayer de faire
récupérer des ballons sous les
chandelles et on peut faire confiance à
Sexton et côté sud-aff aussi
mettre des coups de pied en l'air et ça
fait est-ce que le match est le résultat
du match de samedi soir peut changer la
donne pour Fabien Galtier est-ce qu'il
peut adapter tel ou tel joueur dans sa
composition d'équipe contre l'Italie en
disant lui j'en aurais besoin contre
l'Irlande lui j'en aurai besoin contre
l'Afrique du Sud ou non de toute façon
l'équipe de France est assez forte va
imposer son style de jeu va imposer sa
composition d'équipe quoi qu'il arrive
contre n'importe quelle équipe en quart
de finale disons que contre l'Irlande et
l'Afrique de toute façon il faut mettre
la meilleure équipe les postes donc ça
change pas il peut y avoir des petites
différences en défense duel des non
peut-être que si c'est l'Afrique du Sud
il faut mettre je l'ont parce que très
physique François crosso 6 et c'est un
tout petit peu moins dense mais voilà si
c'est l'Afrique du Sud il faut mettre le
plus lourd
si l'Irlande on peut peut-être mettre un
troisième Link et qui court un peu plus
mais les Galtier c'est pas un type qui
finance beaucoup de ce point de vue là
quand il fait jouer les types avec
lesquels avec les chasubs dans les
entraînements de préparation c'est en
général l'équipe qui joue avec les
chasubles bleus si je suis bien si j'ai
bien lu qui arrive sur le terrain il
cache pas il cache pas son jeu il est
assez cash sur son il y a encore une
fois c'est pas du football quoi football
on peut mettre en demi défensif sur tel
attaquant passe pour bloquer le jeu je
ne sais quoi rugby c'est tout ça est
très collé Jean-Marc parce que j'ai une
information très importante ça vient il
y a donné les premières informations
autour de d'Antoine Dupont on a une
suspicion de fissures de fractures sur
le maxillaire donc ce serait le plus bas
c'est l'os de la mâchoire on va attendre
les examens pour avancer voilà ce que
dit Fabien Galtier
pas très optimiste je crois que c'est
comme ça qu'on va se quitter avec ces
nouvelles vous suivez tout ça sur le sur
Le Figaro.fr Vincent roseron merci
beaucoup vous avez quand même passé un
bon moment au stade Vélodrome
mais bien sûr qu'on a passé un bon
moment forcément on a vu une équipe de
France qui a gagné il y a le résultat on
est forcément inquiet pour Antoine
Dupont on a passé une bonne soirée et
les supporters ont aussi passé une bonne
soirée parce que je peux vous dire que
le vélo de Rome plein pour un match de
rugby c'est quand même une sacrée
ambiance et d'ailleurs ce stade qui va
très vite se transformer parce que
samedi il y a un autre événement
effectivement et ça va démarrer dès en
fait il laisse le stade à minuit il
commence à travailler dessus à minuit
pour accueillir le pape évidemment et
cette messe
aussi sur sur Le Figaro.fr avec Timothée
qui sera sur place Vincent Vincent roux
à l'animation de ce moment historique
merci à tous merci de nous avoir suivis
on est un peu inquiet pour tout vous
dire on a du mal à se satisfaire et à
sauter de joie après cette victoire
large nette sans bavure spectaculaire de
l'équipe de France contre la Namibie 96
à zéro merci de nous avoir suivi merci
aux équipes en régie et puis on se
retrouve par la semaine prochaine on se
retrouve dans deux semaines avec ce
match contre contre l'Italie en
attendant ensuite toutes les
informations autour de l'équipe de
France et de cette Coupe du monde avec
ce match construit tout particulièrement
c'est samedi soir Irlande Afrique du Sud
bonne soirée sur le figure au point fr